This beginner's DevOps course is your first
step toward a DevOps engineering role.
It is taught by the CEO and co founder of LayerCI.
The goal of this course will be for regular
developers and regular engineering practitioners
to learn fundamental DevOps concepts so that
they can go towards the DevOps engineering role.
We'll also be talking about DevOps
broadly in the introduction. But
beyond that will primarily be talking
about the engineering side of things.
DevOps is a methodology that helps
engineering teams build products
better by continuously integrating user feedback.
And if you google DevOps, and you look for
pictures, you'll often see ones like this,
it really helps understand how DevOps
is different than the traditional way
of thinking about software developed.
Back in the day, software was developed,
much like things would be developed in a
factory. So any input would be programming,
and then the output, you'd have a product that
you could put on a CD, and you'd sell it to users.
But since the advent of the Internet,
and have continuously updatable software,
it's become really easy to launch things and get
user feedback and integrate that into the current
product instead of making a new version of the
product. So websites like Facebook, continuously
upgrade instead of requiring you to buy, you
know, a new version of Facebook, unlike, you know,
old games, like some city would require you to buy
a new version of SimCity. And that idea is really
formalized by DevOps, the sections are planning,
where you take a set of features that you want
to build. And you work with your team to make some
specifications for those features might look like,
you code them. So developers on your team will
build out these features so that they can be
released. And of course, they're built. So for
a website, you might take the source code and
bundle it into JavaScript that a user's browser
could run. For a video game, you might make
releases for various different versions that
run on Linux and versions that run on Windows
and versions that run in the browser. So you
take these built artifacts, and you test them.
So testing is both automatic and manual.
Automatic testing is usually colloquially known
as continuous integration. And manual testing
is colloquially known as quality assurance, QA.
And then after it's tested, and you know, the
stakeholders have all given their feedback,
it's released. And continuous deployment
strategies, releasing and deploying all happens
automatically after a change is known to be good.
There's a lot of automation that can be done here.
In larger teams. There's, you know, popular tools
like Spinnaker by netflix that we'll talk about
in later talks. But the core idea is you want to
take the software, and you want to send it to your
users in a way that they don't notice if there's
problems. So if there's an experimental UI change,
you might show it to a few percentage of
users and get their feedback before you
show it broadly. Again, a company like Facebook,
which has billions of users, even if 1% of their
users complain, they'll get hundreds of millions
of emails, the release is built and deployed. So
deploying means it's released to your users for a
website, it would mean it's publicly accessible on
the internet. For a CD ROM, you know, you bundle
your things onto a CD and you distribute that
for a mobile release, you'd build the artifact
and you submit it to the App Store. And then
the App Store would review it and then publish
a new update that your users could download.
And then you operate it. Operating
is primarily things like scaling,
making sure that enough resources exist for
the load, adding more servers as required.
configuring things dealing with
architectural problems, essentially,
on monitoring. So as your users use your software,
and especially as they submit things, and start
jobs and create posts on your forums, you want
to make sure that those posts are all healthy.
And then finally, you take all this feedback,
and you put it back to the planning stage.
So the planning stage takes all the user feedback
takes all of the things that the operations and
deployments, teams learned about deploying
and scaling the product. And then use that
to build out new features, solve bugs, and make
new versions of the back end and new versions of
the architecture. And then just continues in the
cycle. And this is what people mean when they say,
our company uses DevOps, or our company is
tech forward, or our company is digitally
transformed. They mean that instead of taking a
set of requirements and building one artifact,
which is then shipped, it's a continuous cycle
of taking feedback. You know, in these two weeks
Scrum cycles, usually, and producing software
that users actually want to use that they've
had some say in producing DevOps engineering is
another common part of DevOps. So beyond just
the methodology, which is something that maybe
the technical leaders and CEO would care about,
there's a subfield of DevOps engineering,
and this is usually what engineers mean.
You know when they say DevOps, and
that's usually what job postings
mean when they say DevOps. So if a job
posting is asking for a DevOps engineer,
you know, they're not asking for
someone that can plan and deploy
code. They're mostly asking for someone that
can build a test, release, deploy and monitor.
So the three pillars of DevOps engineering, our
pull request automation, deployment, automation,
and application performance management. And we'll
get into specifics about those. But the idea is,
pull request automation helps developers build
things faster, and helps them understand whether
their proposed change is good, faster. Deployment
automation, helps you deploy your code in a way
that users don't complain. Again, Facebook has
lots of deployment automation, because if they
just threw their code out into the void,
every time a developer made a change,
there'd be hundreds of millions of complaints. And
application performance management is automation
around making sure that things are healthy. So
automatically detecting downtime, automatically
waking someone up, if you know, the site goes
down overnight, automatically rolling back
things if there's a problem. And we'll get into
the specifics of all of these in future talks.
The first pillar, which I mentioned
was pull request automation
has primarily to do with the developer feedback
cycle. So developers share work with each other
by proposing these atomic sets of changes
called pull requests. And by atomic I mean,
they're full featured on their own,
they don't require other things to run.
First, it's like if a developer proposes a pull
request, they should be expecting that that change
is good. And as far as they can tell, the change
fulfills some business requirements. And then
what they have to do is get through some gates.
So organizations and pull request automation,
their goal is to make sure that developers can
tell very quickly whether their change is good
or not. So for example, if you're working on a
website, and the developer proposes a change that
adds a typo, that's something that can easily
be automatically detected. And if you set up
a typo gate that says no change may go in if it
contains a typo, that would be an easy way to make
sure that developers get automatic feedback about
their changes. People say pull requests, you know,
as of 2021, usually they mean Git. So Git is
a technology originally popularized by Linux,
and it helps developers make these sorts of
changes and share them with each other. a pull
request is usually reviewed by at least one other
programmer and something called a code review,
where the other programmer will tell you about
code style will tell the proposing programmer,
whether there's architectural problems, scaling
problems, subjective things that can't easily be
automated. But that process of review can also be
greatly facilitated by a DevOps technology stack.
And DevOps automation can help with things like
ephemeral environments, and from linting. And
from all of these other automations that we'll
get into, after the code review has been done.
Usually, an engineering manager or product manager
in charge of the functionality being proposed,
will get feedback. So if you create a new button,
on a website, you'd like the designer that
designed the button, and you'd like the product
manager that requested the button be created.
Both give feedback because if the button is
phrased poorly, if it's placed poorly, if it's not
mobile, responsive, those are all problems that
would require another merge request. So it would
be great if the original merge request fulfilled
all of the requirements, the first time it was
proposed. And so usually, non technical people
will give feedback on pull requests as necessary.
So what can be automated for a DevOps engineer,
you can automate things like
automated test running, per change ephemeral
environments, automated security scanning,
notifications through reviewers, getting the
right people to review it at the right time.
And the end goal of all this automation is that
a developer should be able to propose a change
and get it merged the same day they propose the
change. That's a huge organizational benefit,
because it means that critical bugs can be very
quickly fixed and merged and deployed without
needing a special process. And it also means that
developers aren't bogged down in bureaucracy,
they can propose changes once they get through
all the gates, the change will be deployed,
there isn't additional special gates that
they need to discover. So for example, if the
proper gates and automations have been set up,
a developer should be able to change a web page
without having to ask everyone in the company.
Whether this web page is used in certain workflows
or not. By virtue of passing the tests and passing
the QA review, it's assumed that the new change is
good. And if a problem does arise, a new gate
can be added to the automation so that in the
future problems don't occur. The second pillar is
deployment automation. And the famous post from
2000s, the founder of Stack Overflow, places Can
you make a build in one step as the second most
important question for a development organization,
and things haven't really changed since then.
The efficiency of the build process isn't the
only goal of deployment automation. However,
other goals include the deployment strategies, I
talked about Canary deployments where you want to
show a feature to one user at a time starting
new versions of your application without causing
downtime. If you have to shut off your
website, before upgrading it, and then
turning on the new version, the visitors that
visit the website in the middle of the upgrade
will notice downtime. So there's clever
deployment strategies you can do to avoid that.
And finally, rolling back versions
in case something goes wrong.
It's easy to overcomplicate the planets. Many
companies have complex internal platforms
for building and distributing releases.
Broadly, success and deployment automation
is finding the appropriate deployment tools to
fulfill business goals and configuring them.
And then ideal world there should be little
to no custom code for deploying. So off the
shelf solutions like Spinnaker and harness are
wonderful places to start for this sort of thing.
Finally, application performance management, even
the best code can be hamstrung by operational
errors. There's a famous case where a user put a
bunch of spaces at the end of their post in Stack
Overflow. And they brought down Stack Overflow,
which is a very popular developer website,
because Stack Overflow hadn't deployed their code
in a way that would deal well with a bunch of
whitespace. So a bunch of space characters at the
end of a post, even with the best code, and even
with the simplest things like just a messaging
board, it's easy to have faults that make it to
production and are only uncovered by users. So
application performance management ensures that
metrics like how long it's taking for requests
to be processed, how many servers are being used,
all of those key health metrics are being
processed. And if there's a problem, like if all
of the requests to the landing page are suddenly
taking a long time, the appropriate people can
be notified automatically, instead of an engineer
discovering on Twitter that their website is down.
Logging. So as a program executes, it will
produce logs. And the logs generally have
information about the state of things.
It's useful to be able to map back logs,
like, you know, a user visited the website with
information about that user. So what was their IP
address? What was their username, what resource
did they access and what resources were used
for fulfilling that access. So if they had to
load something from a database, and the database
was slow, it's useful to be able to say, the user
had a slow experience because their request was
fulfilled slowly. But the request was fulfilled
slowly because it was fulfilled from the database
slowly. So mapping these requests all the way down
to their constituent components is very useful.
monitoring. So again, I mentioned metrics
and automatically alerting people, but taking
the logs and metrics, how slower things how
much memory is left, and deciding what to do. So
if there's a bunch of load, you might decide
based on the metrics to automatically scale
the number of servers, so add more web servers
as they're being used. Based on the logs,
if there's errors, you might want to automatically
file tickets for engineers to look into them.
And if there's a downtime, you might want to call
someone the person on call so that they wake up
and take care of the downtime. And they can drop
everything, they can have a pager, so to speak.
And that's alerting. So alerting is when fault
is detected, some trigger has occurred based on
the metrics, some number of requests or to slow
things are unhealthy, you know, users are going
to notice degraded performance, someone should be
notified or something should be done some action,
a new product, shouldn't dive into DevOps,
engineering all at once. So all of that I've
talked about our end goals for really large
organizations like Netflix and Facebook,
developers that add automation
as a situation required.
So a new startup with no users building a website.
pillars two and three are essentially useless
outages won't be noticed by anyone. Something like
a downtime won't be noticed by anyone. It doesn't
necessarily matter. You don't even necessarily
need to run automated tests, a useful stack for
someone there would be something like that low
five, or sell or our product where you can get
staging environments to collaborate with other
developers. But that's about as far as you care
for testing wise, you just get to an environments
for every proposed change. And you can play around
with it yourself to see in a manual QA setting,
whether it's good or not a team building an app
for 10 enterprise users. So enterprise users are
much more sensitive to downtime. So test coverage
and business hours alerting should be priorities.
On logging and log aggregation error
collection, there is popular tools like century
and code Cove for automated test running, there's
tools like bit rise and circle ci vaporizes are
known for mobile testing, and for alerting
There's a famous tool called Pedro duty that
keeps track of who should be notified if there's
a downtime. And so during business hours,
you might assign someone to be the person
that isn't supposed to take any meetings
for the day. If there's a downtime, they
will drop everything and solve the problem.
And a social media app like Reddit might
be using a large combination of things so
century for catching errors in the website,
Elasticsearch LogStash, Kibana is a popular
way of collecting and looking at logs.
pingdom will check whether certain
pages are taking too long to respond.
launchdarkly lets you add feature flags. So
you can say whether a feature is enabled for
some group of users or not, should the new landing
page be shown to users in North America or Europe,
in terraform, lets you automate the deployment
process. So given a set of servers and a set of
things that need to run on the servers, terraform
will help you automatically create a plan to
ensure that the right things
are running in the right places.
And the conclusion of all of this is that DevOps
engineering is vital for developer teams. By being
cognizant of its three pillars, customers will
have a confusing and disappointing experience,
you know, things will go down, things
won't scale properly, things will be slow.
And so it's really important to keep the
three pillars in mind as you're scaling an
engineering organization, or if you're being
hired as a DevOps engineer. new products don't
need to automate very much. However, as the
product matures, and it gets more users,
it's more and more important to automate DevOps
engineering and to dedicate more resources to it.
Very good morning to code review automation. Let's
talk about testing, which is going to be really
vital baseline information for when we talk about
continuous integration, and other code review
automation topic. So test driven development is
a coding methodology, where tests are written
before the code is written. And, you know, we're
gonna explain tests and test driven development in
terms of coffeemakers. So enjoy this picture
of a nice coffee maker, as we continue.
test driven development spun around for a long
time. It was popularized in the early 2000s. And
the idea is simple, but it requires knowledge of
how things came to be for it to really make sense.
So, historically, common words in software
development, like quality assurance, QA,
and unit test have roots in factories building
physical products. If you were running a factory
building coffeemakers, you would test that
it worked at varying levels of completion.
So unit tests, ensure individual
components work on their own.
Does the heater work? Does the tank hold
water? integration tests? ensure a few
components work together? Does the
heater heat the water in the tank?
system end to end tests? ensure
everything works together?
Does the coffee maker brew a cup of coffee
acceptance tests after being launched, sent to
customers? Are they satisfied with the result? Are
they confused with the button layout or breaking
the coffeemaker within their warranty period?
All of these tests have software analogies, it's
useful to know which components break in order
to diagnose a problem. But it's also useful to
know that the whole system is working correctly.
Because even if every individual component works
on its own, and if your coffeemaker doesn't heat
water with its heater, that's going to be
a problem when it comes to making coffee.
That's really the idea for testing. But
let's get into test driven development,
which is the methodology built on top of
testing that's become so popular in the past
10 or 20 years. Most developers that aren't using
test driven development have a similar workflow,
they'll choose something to work on. Based on our
idea of DevOps, it would be in the planning phase,
the developers would find something
to work on in the planning phase,
they build it, so they'd write code, and they'd
make a build from that code. And then they test
it. So they've read small scripts that made
sure that their code was working correctly.
If you're making a function that adds two numbers,
you might pass it to into unexpected The result is
four. And that would be a good indication
that your function was working correctly.
So steps one and three, as it turns out, are
very connected. The tests written at the end
essentially codify the specification, what is
success for building a coffeemaker, it should
heat up in five seconds. So write a test for that.
It shouldn't brew coffee have sufficient strength,
so write a test for that, and so on. test driven
development uses the similarity of steps one in
three to flip this process. So first, developers
choose something to work on. And then they write
the tests before reading the code. So they
write tests that are currently failing because
the specification isn't satisfied. And then they
write code, until all of the specifications they
wrote in step two are satisfied. So they might
make a testing regimen that would work if the
coffeemaker succeeded, and then build the cheapest
coffeemaker, which satisfies that testing regimen.
And the end result is the same. So the software
is built, it's tested, and it matches the
specifications. But it's significantly
easier in a lot of cases to write code.
If you write the tests first because you know what
you're building and it forces you to think about
which things are important to work on and which
things can be put into a later set of change.
So this is a very quick video to discuss
testing. And the next video, we'll talk
about continuous integration, which is really the
DevOps continuation of this idea. See you there.
So we've talked about testing, where developers
read scripts that make sure that their code
continues working way off into the future years
after they've made their code. And that leads
us into our discussion of ci, which is really
one of the big topics that people talk about
in a DevOps context. And ci stands for continuous
integration. It refers to developers continuously
pushing small changes to a central repository
numerous times per day. And those changes are
verified by automated computer software that
runs the tests that the programmers have defined.
So we've gone over what tests are. So let's
talk about why a company would use ci.
Well, ci is really the first step in automating
DevOps. Imagine the very simplest scenario where a
single developer is making a program
that'll be used by a small group of users.
That developer makes the original program releases
it, and the project slowly builds traction.
Now, imagine that developer has
a critical bug a year later.
And they go back to the old code, and they
say, like, gee, this is really bad code.
I've become a better programmer since a year
ago. I don't really understand what's going on
here. But that's really how development works.
Programmers get better year after year. And
they have to read and understand the bad code
that they wrote just a year ago. And the only
way to be confident making changes to that legacy
code that might just be a year old, is to have ci
ci improves developer speed, because new changes
can be made confidently without having to worry
about breaking existing functionality. As long
as the tests pass ci also reduces customer churn.
problems in the software are much less likely to
occur. If you have comprehensive tests that run
automatically. As long as you get those check
marks, you can be reasonably sure that the
core features of your application will continue
working. So how would you integrate ci into your
development process? First, let's talk about the
common branch based development process that many
development teams use. So first, developers
work on a feature branch. So they'll take
the files that are most current, the ones
shown to customers at a specific set of time,
they'll branch off of it. So they'll make
a new copy of the files to work on their
their feature independently of all of the other
developers working on things that make changes
to the various components. So this feature makes
a change to the mobile app, and to the website.
And then on that branch, they'll push it back
to the repository, which is usually something
like GitHub, git lab or Bitbucket. And then
that repository will run ci, so the CI will
be configured on the repository side, it'll run
all of the tests that the programmer has defined.
And then the results of those
tests will be attached to the
pull request. And the pull request is the
developer asking to take their code and to merge
it into the central repository that users will
be shown. So you take the feature branch here,
and you put it at the end, and all of the
other commits that are being shown to users.
And so this commit is now the one
that will be shown to users next,
and the next time is a deployment, the features
that the programmer meet will be visible to users.
And the best part is it doesn't cost you
anything a central Git repositories like GitHub,
git lab and Bitbucket. Most have generous
free tiers, even for organizations minus some
security and access control, you know, permissions
features that you might need. As you scale up, and
ci providers like layer ci, GitHub actions, git
lab pipelines, all have generous features as well.
Their ci, you know, is really made for people
working on websites, that's maybe something to
consider. But if you're really early on in your
projects lifecycle, it doesn't really matter
which ci provider to use. Of course, there's one
thing to take away from the discussion of ci,
it's that ci is a vital tool, it's really
the first thing that should be automated in
most pull request automation schemes. Because
it's so easy. developers should be writing these
tests regardless. And so if you don't run the
tests automatically, slowly, people will break
things without realizing that they're breaking
them. And users will notice those broken things.
And following best practices like feature
branches and ci is a really easy way to
scale a developer team. With just ci,
a developer team can easily scale from
one to 10 developers. And at some point in
there, you'll have to start worrying about
other pull request automation topics, like
the ones we'll cover in the next section.
talk a lot about theory. But let's
get practical for a little bit just
to round out our understanding of
how these DevOps concepts work.
Let's look at what setting up ci
looks like for an actual repository.
torey
This is the live chat example. It's
an open source version of slack.
That's used as a demo repository throughout layer
three is internal documentation. Let's say for
this open source version of slack, we'd like to
run tests every time a developer proposed changes,
so that in the pull requests tab, we'd be
able to know whether a change was good.
In particular, let's say a developer
was changing the color of the website.
In the main website, After you log in
the top bar in sidebar purple,
perhaps the customer has requested
that the color be blue. Instead,
if we asked a developer on our team to make this
change, they would go to the necessary design file
and edit the color.
In this case, there are two colors to change.
If the developer opened this pull request, it'd
be very difficult for us to review their change.
Without a CI system, all we
can see is the file change
and the description of the commit. So we can see
that they've edited main dot CSS, and that they've
changed these color values. But it's very hard
to understand the ramifications of this. And it's
especially hard to understand whether this will
have negative side effects for existing users,
especially for changes that are less
trivial than just changing a color.
For this request, if I was asked to review it,
I would have to pull these changes onto my local
developer machine, run the script locally, and
then evaluate the changes locally. Or I could ask
the developer to set up a screen sharing session,
and they could walk me through the changes. Both
of these add a lot of friction to the development
process. It'd be better if I could evaluate their
changes without needing any involvement
at all entirely through a web interface.
But continuous integration helps. Continuous
Integration allows developers to set up
comprehensive tests, so that if something
doesn't work anymore, after a proposed change,
it says right in the pull request.
Let's close this change for now, and look at
the repository to understand how to set up ci.
And this repository. One of the services is called
Cypress. And it's an end to end Testing Service.
It contains several configurations.
And these configurations
interact with the page with a fake browser.
For example, this test enters
a username and password,
and then logs in and then ensures
that the user is actually locked in
this test goes to the message area enters a
random message and ensures that the message
has actually been submitted that it's
viewable in the remaining chat area.
With enough end to end tests,
you can be reasonably confident
that a chat system like this one
continues working.
So we'd like to run these tests every
time a developer proposes a change.
To do so we'll have to
install a plug in into GitHub,
set up the server to run after every pull
request and run this test against the new server.
To do that, let's set up layers here.
For our use cases, it's easy to just
install it directly onto our GitHub account.
We can now install it onto our GitHub repository.
And now, it's listed here. This means that
we've successfully installed
Lera ci onto this repository.
However, nothing will happen yet.
Because there are no configuration files,
we need to set up a configuration
file for this repository that will
start the whole stack and then run
the tests in Cypress as required.
Let's do that now. Because our
repository is Docker compose based.
Let's use the Docker compose
example as a starting point.
Here, we're going to install Docker, which
is a containerization technology. We'll talk
more about containers versus virtual
machines later on these sets of talks.
Install Docker compose, which is again a way of
running multiple containers at the same time,
these these concepts will become
clear later on in this talk.
We copy the repository files into the test runner.
We build all of the services, we start all of
the services and then we deploy the pipeline.
Let's skip the blank for now we'll talk about that
in the deployment section of this DevOps course.
And after all the services
are started, let's run tests.
Luckily, I've already pre set up a script
for this, so I can copy my configuration.
So to recap, what this configuration will do is
install the necessary software, in
this case, Docker and Docker compose,
copy the repository files,
build all of the micro services,
start them all locally within the test
runner, and then run our tests against them.
So now that we've installed
layer ci onto our repository,
all we have to do is add this configuration,
and we'll have set up ci for it.
So let's click Add File,
we'll name it layer file. This is
how layer C is configuration files
and other ci providers will have
different file names, of course,
we'll copy our configuration.
And we'll commit the file.
So now that we've set up ci, we can see that
there was a dot next to the commit name.
And that dot turns into a checkmark
when the tests have passed.
This means that every time a developer pushes
new code and our source code management tool,
look at a success metric. Namely, whether
the tests have passed or not automatically,
they won't have to run the test themselves.
And the reviewer won't have to trust that the
original developer has actually
tested that the change works.
So let's go back to our original
proposed change of changing the colors
in production from blue to purple.
Here, we're going to make our
change and reopen the pull request.
But because we've configured a CI provider
for it, we'll be able to see that the tests
are running automatically directly
in the pull request view itself.
Now, when our developer asks us for a review,
it'll be much easier for us to be able to tell
whether the change has negatively affected our
customers workflows. In particular, because we've
configured Cypress and later ci to check that
logging in and posting messages still work. Well
know that for this change, even though many files
might have been changed, the core workflows still
work, which gives us a degree of confidence that
nothing terribly bad has happened with the code.
So we can look at the file change for our
first idea of what the developer has done.
And then we can view what the CI is doing.
So if we open the relevant pipeline,
we'll see that the tests are in progress of
running, the new version of the application has
been built and started within the CI runner.
And the tests are running one by one. Here,
it's tested that you can post chat messages
within our alternative slacks chat page,
the landing page loads, and
logging in works correctly.
So now within our pull request view, we'll be
able to see a big checkmark here, which shows
that all of the relevant ci checks have passed.
And then you can even automate within GitHub or
other source code management platforms that
certain checks must pass entirely. So you can
automate that all ci checks must pass before
a change could be merged. Let's make sure that
developers are never reviewing code that's so
obviously broken that it's breaking your tests.
And you don't only have to run end to end tests
here. You can also run linters unit tests and
other versions of tests, which we talked about
throughout this series of talks. And now that
I'm happy with the change, I've reviewed
the files, and I see that the CI has passed,
I can merge it with a great deal more confidence
than if I didn't have this automation in place.
That's it for setting up ci and an applied
setting. Let's get back to
theory for a little bit.
Continuing on the topic of testing
and continuous integration,
let's talk about code coverage. So code coverage
quantitatively measures how comprehensive
The tests for a code base are, you might think
that you have enough tests to find all of the
common bugs and to really check all of the
functionality of your app. But it's hard to
put a number on it. Unless you're measuring
code coverage. This is what a code coverage
graph looks like from a popular tool.
Each of these squares represents a file,
and the color represents how many tests are
covering that file. So bright green means 100%
of the file is tested. And bright red means
none of the file is tested. So that would
be a priority of a file that should either
be tested or excluded from the measurement.
So let's say you're taking
over an existing code base,
it's relatively large at 100,000 lines of code.
Over the years, it's been adopted by a couple
100 users, and you're expected to maintain it
and add features without harming those users. So
the first place you look at is the unit tests,
which we discussed earlier. But they weren't
really prioritized by the previous maintainers.
So there's a mismatch of libraries and naming
conventions. And it's kind of hard to tell
which tests are testing which files
and which files need to be tested.
And before you write any new features,
you'd like an objective way to measure
how sensitive certain parts of the codebase are to
being changed. If something has very comprehensive
tests, you'll be much less scared to make changes
and add features that touch that part of the code
than if there's a part of the code that doesn't
have pests. So this is where code coverage really
shines. You've got a complicated code base that
has existing users, you'd like to enforce that
tests are written so that things aren't broken
in an objective way. So getting into the first
code of this whole series, let's look at this
JavaScript function, which I will make bigger.
So this is a very simple
function, if not a bit contrived.
It takes a number.
And it defines a few variables. It loops up to
that number, pushing strings into a results list.
And then every 50 elements, it pushes
a special string into the results list.
So this whole function is 10 lines of
code. But not all 10 lines are equal. So
really, there's three kinds of lines in a
program like this. There's the syntax lines,
like these closing ones that don't actually
have any code in them. They're simply syntactic
constructs for the programmers benefit.
They don't you know, it doesn't even
make sense to test these because how would
you test that a semi colon existed or not?
There's logic lines like this one, which
actually have side effects. And by side effects,
I mean that these lines, if you remove them,
would change the behavior of the program.
And those branch lines like this one,
which changed the flow of the program.
So for loops, and if statements in programming are
used, as constructs that change the order of the
commands that run, so this if
statement, if it evaluates to true,
would run this line. And if it didn't evaluate to
true, it wouldn't run this line. So to reiterate,
the three kinds of lines are syntactical ones that
don't do anything. The actual logic ones that have
effects, and the branch ones that
change which lines of code execute.
And code coverage is usually defined
as line coverage. So it's the ratio
of the non syntax lines which are executed by
tests over the total number of non syntax lines.
So again, consider this test.
If you expect the function
should work with the input to
and you manually calculate what the
function should return for the input to
this would be a unit test for your function.
But since you're only executing it on the input
to this if statement, which requires an input
of at least 50 to execute, wouldn't run. So you'd
be testing this line, it would execute this line,
it would execute and this line, which
would also execute, so you'd be executing
five out of six lines,
and the deed that would be 83% test
coverage. So just the single test gets
us most of the way to understanding our
function and understanding its problems.
related concept is called branch coverage. So
instead of measuring how many lines of code it
measures groups of lines, in our example,
above, there's only two branches. There is
the main branch. There's the body of the for
loop, and there's actually a third branch called
The if statement body. So here at this line
will always execute the body of the for loop.
will only execute if i is less than n. so here
you need and to be greater than or equal to one,
or these lines to execute. And this line will
only execute if i is greater than or equal to 49.
And so branch coverage would be how many
individual branches out of these three are
evaluated to true by a test. So you'd like
to know how many of all of the branches
are tested. And this is useful because if this
line of code executes, then this line of code
will always execute. So treating them both as
individual things that need to be tested, doesn't
really mean as much as taking the bodies of these
statements as things that need to be tested.
And if you measured the test with branch coverage,
you'd see the two of the three branches
or x evaluated during the test.
So when should you care about this line coverage
in branch coverage, we've already discussed one
scenario where you've inherited an existing code
base. However, it's important in many different
situations. In general, you should measure
and optimize for code coverage. If any of
the following are true. Your product has users.
And those users might leave if they're affected
by bugs, in which case, it's important to
measure code coverage because it lets you
work with your team to improve the code coverage
and reduce the number of bugs. You're working
with developers that aren't immediately
trustworthy, like contractors or insurance,
that you're bringing them into your code base,
they need to make changes in some fixed timescale,
like form up internship. So they can immediately
become experts in the entire code base.
And you'd like them to be able to make changes
without worrying too much about things breaking.
Or, if you're working on a very large code
bases, many individually testable components.
Your code coverage analysis can complement test
driven development, which we talked about in the
previous talk, to make sure that everyone on the
team is generally working on important things,
and that the things they make
won't break in the future.
So it's a common mistake in code review automation
to make things too rigid before the product has
enough users, if you force developers to get
100% branch coverage, so to write two to five
unit tests for every function, it's going to
make them much slower at developing features
that users will actually notice. Remember
that tests are never viewed by users.
So the only thing that users care about is the
stability of the system. So if you have an MVP,
or if you have a product that doesn't have very
many active users, yet, it might not be worth
it to measure or optimized for branch coverage.
until those users care a lot about stability.
And by writing unit tests, and other types of
tests, an important thing to keep in mind is that
developers are solidifying the implementations
of features that they might have to throw out.
If you build a feature, and it ends up not
being something that your users actually want,
it's always a better idea to throw out
that feature, then build it long term. So
if a developer builds a feature, and writes many
tests for it to improve the code coverage of that
feature, they'll be much more likely not to throw
it out, because they'll feel a sense of ownership.
And they'll feel a sense of sunk cost in having
built this feature and made it good, so to speak.
So it's important not to over optimize for
these things before, they're important. And
it's a subjective idea. But really, you'll notice
when your users start complaining about stability.
So organizationally, there are some
common policies related to code coverage.
The first one is useful when you inherit a code
base. And the policy is that code coverage must
not decrease. This one is one of the easiest ones
to automate. It's especially useful if you're
taking over an existing code base, as I mentioned.
And the idea is that code coverage ratio should
never decrease. If the current code has 75% of
its lines tested, and your new change introduces
40 lines of code, at least 30 of those lines
will need to be tested. Otherwise, your changes,
code coverage would be less than 75% 30 out of 40.
And you'd be decreasing the average code coverage.
As with most code coverage policies, this will
increase stability, so there'll be less bugs
because things will be better tested at the
expense of developer speed. So developers
will have to make some complicated tests,
and they might spend a lot of time making
testing infrastructure. So features will be
shipped less quickly if you make this sort of
policy. And if you enforce it
with code review automation.
unfortunate side effect of this policy is
that changes that would be harder to test
such as integrations will be less
likely to be worked on by developers.
So developers are incentivized by
their paycheck and by their manager to
ship features quickly to make many features
per Scrum cycle. And so if certain features are
harder to test, because they require internet
connectivity, or connected third party API's,
those features will be harder to make and
harder to test. And so developers will be
less likely to make them regardless of
whether they're important to the users or not.
So it might be useful to have an exemptions policy
in place for things like third party integrations.
If your organization decides to go for this
code coverage must not decrease policy.
Another useful policy is code owners for test
files. If you've used code coverage automation
to keep code well tested, it's often beneficial to
define code owners for the tests themselves. This
means that developers can change implementation
details without formal reviewers. But logic
changes. So the tests define what success means
for a function or for an algorithm, then, changing
the tests for a new implementation would need
to be approved by a senior developer or manager.
in GitHub, with an engineering manager, a GitHub
code owners file might contain this, which means
that spec dot j s is a common JavaScript testing,
naming convention. And at engineering manager
username means if, if there's a file called code
owners, which contains this, then the engineering
manager will need to approve any change, which
changes a test, which is probably a good policy.
So if you're working in a large code base
with test driven development, especially,
or if you're hiring interns, or contractors, or if
your users are especially sensitive to bugs, and
you're afraid that they'll have a bad experience,
if the even small bugs make it to them,
it might be in your team's best interest to
install a code coverage measurement tool.
And at the time of writing, these
are the three most common ones in
the open source world code coverage,
coveralls and Code Climate.
So we've talked about testing, and we've talked
about continuous integration. And those are
really like the initial things that are set up
in a DevOps code review automation pipeline.
But the problem is that it requires the
developers to be on board. And of course,
developers are probably busy building
features and might not necessarily want to
make tests or improve test coverage.
So let's talk about linting,
which is something that approximates testing, but
doesn't need the developers to spend any time.
linters are programs that look at a program source
code, and find problems automatically. They're a
common feature of pull request automation, because
they ensure that obvious bugs do not make it to
production, obvious here in quotes. So an example
of linting. Let's again, look at a JavaScript
program, the very simple one, you should
understand even if you don't know JavaScript,
it defines a variable var x equals five,
and defines a function but continues
after the open bracket, which is generally
considered bad practice. It uses let for the
second variable and defines it with the same name
as the first one. So this is just confusing, and,
you know, wouldn't be called good code, a code
reviewer would mentioned this in a code review.
And then it says while x is less than 100,
console, log x, and then it closes the while loop
on this line, and it messes up the end Det. These
three lines should be indented for consistency,
and then it closes the function. Finally, you
should realize that this while loop goes forever.
x isn't incremented in the body of the while
loop. So just by looking at the code statically
without running any environment or looking
at the code with a browser even, you can
tell that this loop will run forever, and that's
probably something a programmer didn't intend.
So
much of this feedback could be automated, a set
of rules like don't shadow variables. Never name
a variable in an inner scope that has the
same name as a variable in an outer scope
could be applied to each proposed change, so that
human reviewers would not have to waste effort
leaving code style comments. tools that
maintain and run such lists are called linters.
relevantly, another class of code review
feedback has to do with code style.
It's easy for coder bureaus to waste time pointing
out stylistic choices like tabs versus spaces, or
camel case versus pothole case. These
discussions bring no value to end users,
you know, your customers don't care what case
your code is written in. And ultimately, they just
serve to cause resentment and missed
deadlines within engineering teams.
If a review takes an extra couple hours
because of comments like this, that's a
couple hours that the programmer could have been
focusing their attention on another feature.
So engineering organizations should eventually
adopt to maintain a global style guide.
But in most cases, just starting with
something like the Google Style Guide,
which is open source and available at
this link, is a great starting point.
These guides often come with linter
configurations, which help everything
Stay stylistically similar, and some programming
languages like Python and go come with their own
style guides and automation, like Pep
eight. In the case of Python that will
make it easy for developers using those
programming languages to stay in a unified style.
an organizational thing you can do for code
style is to knit, or which stands for nitpicking.
Instead of blocking at the code review stage, if
there's review feedback that a code style review
feedback, it might be better for code reviewers
to leave small review comments called mitts.
So they'd say knit full colon
shouldn't be styled this way.
This is great. Because it allows the reviewers to
merge something with a few pieces of feedback
so that ours don't have to be spent on
a small piece of refactoring that could be
done in a later state at a later point of time.
Once the style guide is adopted, it's possible
to configure tools to automatically format code
to follow the Style Guide, which tools are called
Auto formatters. And the programming language go,
which we use at layer ci, a command such as
the following would use the standard format
are the one that comes with go to clean up
all of the source files in the repository.
So we'd use the Janu, find command,
find the files that have a go extension,
and we'd exec go format on them. And this
will take all of the source files and then
format them with their style guides
so that they all pass the style guide.
And of course, if your ci system is running tests
automatically, every time your code is pushed,
the code could be automatically limited as
well. Programmers shouldn't have to wait for
a human reviewer to tell them whether the code is
limited and styled appropriately. In most cases,
it's cheap and convenient to run linting and
formatting automatically with a CI system.
So an easy solution is you get another
checkmark. To get something set up quickly,
it's a good start to make lint act the same as
running a unit test in ci, so add an x if the
code isn't listed properly, and then the developer
can very quickly get stylistic feedback without
needing to talk to another human or wasting their
reviewers time for getting this sort of feedback.
And a CI configuration that might look like this.
So copy the project files, run the linting the
script. And then if the linting script fails,
the whole pipeline would fail. This approach
stops reviewers from the picking style, it passed
the linter is a perfectly reasonable response to
an overly zealous code reviewer. So even simple
automation like this can improve the development
speed of entire development teams. It also stops
reviewers from having to give style feedback at
all, at all of the checks for code review pass,
like it passes all of the linters
done the committed stylistically Okay,
the reviewer might still leave some feedback for
future reference, but they shouldn't be blocking
commits getting to production because of small
stylistic choices that aren't even in the linter.
A better long term solution is
to set up a commit back button,
which is common idea that happens all over
the place and code review automation. But
in this specific example, it might look like
this. So you'd say if the code is not limited,
run, yes, lint with the dash dash fix flag,
which again, goes through all of the source
files. Yes, lint is the linter for JavaScript.
So this would go through all of the source files.
For each of them, it would apply the linting
rules, and it would fix any stylistic
errors. And then it would create a commit
an additional, you know set of file changes
on top of what the developers proposing.
And it would create a new branch with a suffix
listed. And it would push to that branch.
So that developer pushes unlimited code, the bot
would automatically create a commit which lifted
everything and it would create a new branch so
that if the developers code was known to be good,
the reviewer could simply merge the Linton
branch instead of the developers original one.
And then we failed the pipeline with lint
failed. This means that the unlimited version
can't be merged. But the limited one, assuming
all the feedback that isn't listed related,
could be merged. So we'd have two branches, the
one the developers proposing and the limited one,
the code reviewer would look at the one that
wasn't rented. They'd say whether it was good
or not, like the logic of the commit was good.
And if it was good, then the reviewer in GitHub
could merge this branch instead of
the one they were asked to review.
This branch would be the same as the original
one with an additional commit on top of it.
So some examples of limiters
for many programming languages.
JavaScript the standard as a 2021 is Eastlands.
TypeScript. Also now uses Eastlands, Python you
piland and flake eight. c++ is much more
subjective. But a common choice is Google
CPP lens from the Google style guide mentioned
above, go comes with a format called go format,
which acts somewhat like a linter. Although
there's additional libraries available for rules
beyond that, Java has checkstyle and find bugs,
maybe older options, but there's a lot of choices
for languages like Java. And Ruby has broke
rubocop and pronto. We've seen users commonly use
and Java, JavaScript C sharp, and many other
languages can be lifted with sonar cube,
which is a popular static analysis
framework that is commonly used at
larger enterprises. But it has an open source
version, that is a good place to start for
10 developer teams that would
like to set up static analysis.
And finally, it was a startup called
Deep source that we've talked to
startup to startup. And they're doing all sorts
of interesting stuff with static analysis as well.
Static Analysis is just the practice of
looking at source code without running it
and finding bugs. So I'd encourage
you to look at deep source as well.
So in comparison to most other code automation
tools, linters are exceptionally easy to set up.
Any team with more than one developer
should almost immediately set up a linter.
To catch obvious bugs like infinite loops. Just
by looking at the code, the linter would be
able to tell you whether there was a common
programmatic error like an infinite loop.
Automatic linting comes standard has many code
editors. So it would be wise to teach developers
how to configure their code editors to use
the existing linting rules that your team
has set up in the CI automation, so that the
developers don't have to wait to push their
code to get this feedback, they can get the
yellow squigglies directly in their editor.
And then teams working on earlier products.
Mentors can help avoid writing unit tests at all.
Instead of relying on a test
suite, you can rely often on
a static analysis to find common bugs
like the code not compiling at all or
infinite loops or stylistic problems.
This helps small teams refer their product
has many users get feedback without
needing to lock things in with tests.
Right. So that's it for linting and
code style. We'll see in the next video.
Let's finish up our discussion of
code review automation by talking
about ephemeral environments, which are
really the latest and greatest when it
comes to doing code reviews and helping
developers get their changes merged.
ephemeral environments are temporary environments
that contain a self contained version of the
entire application. Generally, for every feature
branch, they're often spun up by a slack bot,
or automatically on every commit using DevOps
platforms like later ci itself, or Heroku.
Temporary environments are overtaking traditional
ci platforms as the most valuable DevOps code
review experience. Because these environments
are made on every change all of the stakeholders,
not just developers, but the product, people in
the designers can review a change without needing
that set up a developer environment or asking to
screen share with the developer that proposed it.
So for a more concrete example, let's
say developer is changing something
on a website. So they're changing, you know,
the front end or the back end, or, you know,
some component of the website. And they'd
like to get feedback on the proposed change.
So a code reviewer would look at the
code and they might not understand what
the visual ramifications of that change
are. But within the femoral environments,
within the code review view itself, the reviewer
would just have to click that button there.
I'll zoom in. So within GitHub, this is what the
reviewer would see. They'd See The Description,
the code change, but also a button to view the
ephemeral environment. And when they click that
button, it wakes up a version of the website
specifically with this proposed change in it
so that the reviewer can actually
take a look at things and
see whether the changes is visually
and workflow wise, working well.
In general, ephemeral environments
like halfway between development
environments and staging environments.
At the extreme staging is entirely
replaced by formal environments in
something called continuous staging.
Benefits of ephemeral environments.
Well, the most common reason to adopt
an ephemeral environment workflow is that is that
it accelerates the software development lifecycle.
Developers can review the results of changes
visually, instead of needing to exclusively give
feedback on the code change itself. Additionally,
developers can share their work with non technical
collaborators such as designers as easily
assuring a link to the proposed version.
So
You could post a slack message like this
saying, could you go to this link and
give me feedback instead of needing to
set up a zoom call to share your screen
to get the other person to
look at your proposed changes.
The hardest part of setting up ephemeral
environments are dealing with state.
So dealing with things like
databases and microservices,
by their nature, you know, ephemeral
environments are temporary.
They're isolated from production environments, and
really only lasts as long as a pull request does.
A reviewer should be able to delete a resource
in a review. So they should be able to see if you
know, deleting a user still works without fear
of that affecting the production environments.
So in the early implementation of ephemeral
environments, it might make sense to connect
API servers with read only permissions to a
staging database. So if you're using AWS, you
might have an Iam role that has read only access
to the database. But in that case, you wouldn't be
able to sign up to the service, for example,
because that would require database rights.
The end goal should be to have a fresh
copy of the database for every commit.
So every time a developer
proposes a change, they get
the new database specifically for their
environment that they can do whatever they want in
an ideal ephemeral database has
three attributes. It's pre populated,
so it contains representative anonymized data.
The past security audits of PII, personally
identifiable information must be scrubbed
from databases used in ephemeral environments.
It should be undoable. So if in the course of
review data is deleted, it should be easy to reset
the database to its original state. This is also
crucial for reading destructive end to end tests,
which we'll get into later.
And it should be migrated,
the database should use the schema currently
used in production, it's not very useful to
know if something's working with an old version
of the schema. One of the most common classes
of problems uncovered by formal environments or
broken or nonperformance database migrations.
Another hard problem to solve with ephemeral
environments is the life cycle. So when would you
create them and when you destroy them? The classic
approach is to title lifecycle of a pull request
to the lifecycle of an ephemeral environments. So
if the developer opens a pull request, create an
environment for them, keep it running 24. Seven
until the developer deletes the environment.
The biggest factor to consider there is cost.
If each FML environment costs 10% of production.
So it's 10% cheaper, and you have 30 open pull
requests, you'd be quadrupling your monthly costs.
So you know, that's an expensive developer tool.
Another approach is to create a chat ops bot that
allows creating new environments for a specific
branch with a specific timeout. So for example,
the user type slash PR bot creates in the GitHub
issue description that could create an environment
or in Slack, the user could do the same thing.
This requires the environment to be provisioned
at the time that it's required, which can be slow.
And it's again, hard to tell when to delete these.
The best approach is to create an
ephemeral environment for every change.
So similar to the PR workflow, but
hibernate them as they're provisioned.
There's only a few providers that do this. So one
is Heroku, which will, with Heroku review app can
turn on and off environments. And the other
one is layer ci, shameless plug, I suppose.
So as users use the environments, and layer
ci, there'll be a hybrid ninja not enough.
You can automate this yourself with memory
snapshotting, but it's somewhat involved. So
this might be something that's better
left to using a third party for.
And back to that idea of continuous staging.
The idea is to merge staging ephemeral
environments and a CI pipeline altogether. So this
is kind of layer ci itself primarily sells to our
users. As your ephemeral environments become more
powerful and easier to create. They approach and
overtake many aspects of traditional continuous
integration pipelines. So if you can set up
the website, and the back end and the database,
then it's relatively easy to run tests because
tests are usually much easier to wrap them the
entire back end. At its logical conclusion, this
concept becomes continuous staging, where ci CD
and ephemeral environments form a single
ci CD flow where a single base sets up all
of the requirements for everything. And then that
forks off into the unit tests but also the server
but also how the review environment but also the
linter is everything comes from that common base.
If you're going to make them
yourself, you should probably budget
about a month, or a month of time
it took to set up your environment.
So if your production environment has many
different microservices and has many different
databases, it'll be relatively difficult
to set up an ephemeral environment flow.
Large companies like Facebook have set
this up for their internal pull requests.
But they haven't hired developer teams,
infrastructure software engineers that do this.
So if you're a smaller company, you might want to
stick to a hosted service again, like layer ci,
instead of making it yourself up to
maybe when you have about 20 developers.
And to avoid having to micromanage
starting and stopping environments,
it's easiest to use a hosted provider. If
you're doing just front end development.
Some popular choices are for cell netlify. But
if you're doing full stack deployments, really
the only choices available right now are layer
ci itself and Heroku review apps. There are some
options available in many source code platforms
like Git lab has a environments feature.
But it's not really truly an ephemeral
environments feature. So you should
explore all of those options
make an informed decision.
So that was ephemeral environments.
And that concludes our discussion of
code review automation.
Because pull request automation is
such a core part of DevOps engineering,
let's do another applied tutorial here.
In this example, we'll be setting up
a femoral environments the same way
we talked about before using a hosted
platform for the sake of simplicity.
So because we've already set up ci for this
repository, we already have our layer file,
which is our CI configuration. However, many ci
providers including layer ci, Roku, and others
can set up ephemeral environments, which
are small production deployments you can use
to evaluate the changes live as a reviewer. Again,
let's say we're changing the color this time back
from blue to purple. And we'd like someone to be
able to efficiently review our change, not just by
looking at the test results, but also by looking
at the federal environments. To read manual QA,
you might see, in this case, it's actually very
easy to set up. Let's go to our web micro service.
Let's create a new file.
Here, we'll make another layer file so that
they run in parallel. And we'll
say from our base layer file,
we'll say expose website.
And we'll expose the website running inside the
runner itself. Later ci has this expose website
directive, but many other providers have
similar functionality that you can set up.
And let's jump right to
creating a pull request for it.
So here, our code reviewer would
not only see the test results,
as you can see, those are
here, the initial layer file.
Let's look at the actual
graph to understand better what's going on. Here
we have our tests running in the main layer file.
The main layer file has again built all of
the services started all of the services.
And now it's running our Cypress tests
the same way it did in the CI chapter.
But after the Cypress tests run, we'll have a
second environment, which is inheriting from
the first and that second environment will have
a clickable link that can be used for manual QA.
So let's see that here.
The snapshot is done being taken of the tests,
which means that the ephemeral
environment can start being built.
And now you can see that it's built a staging
server button, and you can connect to it here.
So in our actual pull request, now that all
of the tests and ci services have passed,
we can click the femoral environment button.
As soon as it appears.
We could click the main layer file details,
we can click the services
web ephemeral environment,
and we can click View website. And
what this does is it wakes up the
pipeline which we initially set up to run our
tests. But it forwards the internet visible link
to the web server inside. So here
we've created a fresh environment,
specifically for this test, and we can see
that the test has run and sent the message.
And we can evaluate this change so we can
test that creating channels works for example.
And that in the test channel, it's
still possible to set messages.
This means that you don't need 100% test coverage
to be able to understand the nuance of a channel
For every pull request, you'll be able to
spin up a new environments automatically,
and then wake up that environment
when a review needs to be completed.
And now that we're satisfied with the environment
works correctly, we can merge the pull request.
And from now on, all changes which edit
the website can be manually curated,
so the reviewer can check that things work,
but also a QA team or a designer or a product
manager might be able to check that
the change actually changes what it's
supposed to do. That's it for formal
environments. Let's get back to theory.
Welcome to DevOps Academy deployments. And this
one, we'll be talking about foundational concepts.
And primarily, when you talk about
deploying, you're talking about VMs.
And you're talking about containers. And
containers are often also known as Docker.
So let's talk about the difference between those
two. Before we talk about deploying anything.
People talk about DevOps deployments, they're
usually talking about the point that Linux,
a large portion of all
deployments are to Linux servers.
And containers are really only defined in
terms of Linux, in production as of right now.
So with all that in mind, let's
talk about Linux in the abstract.
So what Linux really helps you do is take care
of four things when you're writing programs,
it takes care of memory. So programs need memory
to do things, memory is also known as Ram.
And since you only have a finite amount of it,
Linux itself needs to figure out which programs
will get which sections of memory, so which ram
sticks will have which programs running on them.
Linux also takes care of processors. So
if you're running two things in parallel,
Linux will make sure that the right amount
of processors are dedicated to both.
If you're, if you've ever run very computationally
intensive tasks on a laptop, you might notice that
your browser gets laggy. That's because
it's not getting enough processor time.
So if you're running production
workloads, Linux needs to make sure
that every program is getting its fair share
of processor time to run the actual program.
Because disk, so Linux takes the files of all
programs and allocate space on the disk for them,
you might have multiple disks, and you might
have both spinning disks and solid state drives,
you might even have disks shared across networks.
So Linux takes care of all of that and make sure
that the right files are on the right disks,
and that programs have access to those files.
And finally, there's devices. So
even beyond disk memory, and CPU,
there's things like GPU. So for
machine learning, you see GPU often,
and things like network cards, which
you use for connecting to the internet.
Linux needs to take these individual resources
and allocate them to processes. So if you have
five processes trying to connect to the internet
at the same time, but only one network card,
Linux needs to make sure that the right
messages are sent to the right websites
upstream. And the responses are sent
to the right programs downstream.
So in a diagram, this is
what that would look like.
So here we have three programs, Chrome,
Notepad, and Spotify. And they're all
running in Linux. So this is assuming you have
a Linux server running these three programs.
And here you have the four shared resources. So
Chrome, asks for CPU, and Linux will allocate
some of the CPU time to Chrome. And it'll also
allocate something notepad and some to Spotify.
And similarly for all the other shared resources.
So this is great, but there's too much
sharing going on. What I mean by that is that
programs know about each other. So if you
had a program that accept expected a file at
home calling file dot txt,
then it could create that file,
but another program could delete or read that
file. so files can be read across programs. And
that means those programs can communicate between
each other, which isn't always what you want.
So, for example, programmers often use
different versions of Python. Python is
a popular programming language. And
there's two popular versions used.
One is Python two, and one is Python three, but
they're both called Python. So if the file at
user bin Python is a Python two executable, and
you try to run a Python three program with it,
then that program would error because you'd be
using the wrong version of Python to run it.
However, some of your programs might need Python
two, and some of them might be Python three.
So here, there's cross talk between programs in
that they're both reading user bin Python, but
they expect there to be different files there. So
that's what I mean by programs overshare sometimes
They need different versions
of files at the same place.
And so you can't really run
both programs at the same time.
Similarly, two web servers might listen
to Port 80. That's how websites allow you
to connect to them. So if you're running
two web servers that both expects Port 80,
to be open, the first one will start
correctly. And the second one will crash,
saying that Port 80 is already used these
sorts of problems of sharing resources
is really where virtual machines and containers
shine. They allow you to separate resources like
files and ports between programs so that
programs can't step on each other's feet.
So here, if you are running your
three programs in that container,
it would look remarkably similar.
So Chrome would be running,
but it would be running within a container.
And that container would be talking to Linux,
which would then allocate the container
resources. And similarly for the other programs.
Now, this might not make sense yet. But let's talk
about what actually happens when you put something
in a container like this. So what happens when
there's a container between a program and Linux?
The big change is that each
program will get its own
version of shared resources
like files and network ports.
The container running chrome might create
a file at tilby slash chrome slash cash.
While the container running notepad could
read that file and see that it didn't exist,
they get different copies
of all of the systems files,
so that they couldn't talk amongst each
other, or have conflicting Python versions.
Similarly, if you had two web servers running
that both expected to be able to open port 81,
would be able to open port 80 in their container,
and the other would be able to open port 80 in
their container. So you can have two programs
both thinking that there are the only program
listening on port 80. But really, they'd
be isolated within their own containers.
So in Linux containers work by creating
namespaces, which are a Linux feature
that groups shared resources together. If
you had five processes running together
within a Docker container, they'd still
be running within Linux itself. But they
would not see the other processes, the
ones on the main Linux machine itself.
So within the container, if you ran PS, au x, and
you counted how many lines of output there were
VSD UX is how you see the running commands
in the Linux machine, you might see 10. And
that means that there was 10 processes visible
to you within the container. But within Linux,
so within the container up here, if you said how
many processes were running, it would say there's
10 processes. But within Linux itself, you'd see
hundreds of processes running, including the 10
from this container. So the containers are kind
of sandboxed or namespaced, into a single group of
processes where the processes can't see the files
outside of the container, or the processes or the
network ports outside of the container. They
only see the ports within this container.
So essentially, what's happening is the programs
are asking, what are the contents of user lib
Python, in our example before and instead of
answering truthfully, Linux is answering with
the contents of another file. So the container
says what is user lib Python, and then Docker,
if you were using Docker for your containers would
respond with the contents of this file var lib,
Docker overlay Fs one user lib Python, which is
a totally separate file in the global system.
So each container would have
its own view of the files.
This little deception allows programs to run in
parallel, because Linux would be would respond
with different files for each container. One
container could have Python pointing at a Python
two executable, and one container could have
Python pointing at a Python three executable.
So if that's how containers work, then
how to VMs work, how are they different?
Well, VMs are very similar to
emulators. If you've ever seen
someone running an older video game on
a modern computer, they're using a VM.
So the idea for containers
was to provide fake Linux.
Within the container they don't really
know they're running with within a
container. They see files, but the files
are simply pointing at a different place
within the real Linux installation. The
idea for VMs is to produce fake versions
one level below that. So pretty produce fake
versions of the CPU, RAM disk and devices.
The VM equivalent of Docker
is called a hypervisor.
It's the program which is in charge of creating
the VMs. So when a VM is running something,
it corresponds to an instance
of the hypervisor within Linux.
The hypervisor might lie to the VM and say
there's one SSD attached. There's one drive
attached and then has 50 gigabytes of capacity.
But then when the VM writes to that drive,
it would instead go to a file, it wouldn't go to
a real drive. And then on the host, it might be
This file. So when the VM itself is writing to
the file, it's actually going through this file,
which is very similar to the deception of
matching files directly that the container
had. But there's some practical differences. The
first is that VMs are very powerful. You can use
them to run other operating systems, such as
Mac OS, or Windows, and different hardware
configurations, you can emulate a gamecube,
or an apple two within a Linux hypervisor.
in containers, it's the processes that are being
lied to, they must still have been the sort of
thing that would run within Linux itself. But
in VMs, there's a nested operating system that
generally doesn't know it's not talking to the
real hardware. When the OS writes things to its
drive, for example, those rights are sent to
a file in Linux instead of a physical drive.
So
when the process writes to the
operating system within the VM,
that operating system sends the right to
a drive, or what it thinks is a drive,
but that drive goes through Linux,
and Linux actually maps it to a file.
Various benchmarks show that CPUs and VMs are
about 10 to 20%, slower than containers. VMs also
usually use 50 to 100% more storage, because they
need all of the things that an operating system
would need. Duplicate containers don't need all of
the files, they only need the application files.
And finally, VMs use about 200 megabytes more
memory for the operating system itself. Again,
containers don't need all of the operating system
because it's the processes that are being lied to.
So VMs use more memory, they're
slower, and they need more storage.
So given these performance benefits, it looks
like containers are almost always a better choice.
And in most cases they are However,
there's a few cases where VMs are a better
choice. Again, VMs mean virtual machines.
If you run in untrusted, so user supplied
code, it's difficult to be confident that
they can't escape a container. This
has gotten better in recent years,
but it's long been a contentious point. Virtual
Machines are much older and much more mature. So
if you're running untrusted code, usually it's
a good idea to put that within a container.
If you're running a Windows or Mac OS script,
so you're running a script that only runs on
another operating system, you'd need to use a
VM for similar reasons. Or if you're running
an old video game that doesn't run in Linux,
and you'd like to run it on a Linux computer,
you'd need to VM. And vice versa, if you're
using VMs, and other operating systems,
if you'd like to run a Linux program in Windows,
you'd usually have to use a VM to run it.
And finally, you can emulate hardware
devices like graphics cards with a VM.
So if you're testing that your graphics card
works correctly, you could emulate the response
that it would give and then test that the
operating system is working as expected.
So that's the big difference
between VMs and containers.
And these are really the two
things that you often deploy.
So let's go into actual deployment strategies
in the next talk. I'll see you there.
Let's keep talking about deployments. So rolling
deployments are one of the most popular deployment
strategies. And we'll talk about the pros and cons
of different deployment strategies throughout this
section. Rolling deployments themselves work
by starting a new version of the application,
sending traffic to the new version, to make sure
everything's okay, and then showing off the old
version and repeating that until all versions of
the old version or versions of the new version.
I realize I've said version many times. So let's
look at pictures that will
help illustrate the point.
This is the myrn app. myrn stands for
MongoDB, Node JS, react, and express js. Here,
the user's web browser connects to
both the front end and the back end,
where front end is the stuff that the user
sees. And back end is the services that
provide connections to the database. So if
you log in, you're connecting to the back end.
If you're just viewing the landing page,
you're connecting to the front end.
Let's say your app has enough traffic that users
will notice if it goes down for a little while.
How would you push a new version of the
application without causing downtime.
This is where rolling deployments come in. The
high level algorithm for a rolling deployment
looks like this. So you create an instance of
the new version of the backend say, you wait
until it's up. So you keep trying to connect to
it until you get a response that satisfactory.
And then you delete an old version and
route the traffic to the new version.
If any instances of the old version still
exist, go back to step one and repeat.
And our myrn example, we'd initially
see three instances of the initial
version and one instance of the new
version. And we'd repeat the process
Until we had three instances of the new version
and one instance of the initial version.
So here, all of the versions are the back end.
And we add a new version of the new back end. And
we turn off a version of the old back end. And we
keep repeating that. So as time goes on, the red
ones replaced the pink ones. And then after a few
loops of this, the only ones remaining are red
ones, we've added a red one, remove the pink one,
added the red one, remove the pink one. And we're
red is the newest version of the application.
So what are the benefits of rolling deployments
over other ways of deploying things? Well, they're
well supported. Rolling deployments are relatively
straightforward to implement. In most cases,
they're natively supported. And several
orchestrators, if you've heard of Kubernetes,
for example, Kubernetes helps you with
this. AWS, Amazon Elastic Beanstalk
also supports rolling deployments.
They don't have huge bursts. So in another
deployment strategy, which we'll talk about,
if you had three versions of the back end, you
need to start six in total, to deploy the new
version, and then you turn off the old three.
So doubles for the duration of the deployments,
the amount of things running, which might
be difficult if you have a finite number
of servers, for example. It's also not
uncommon for services like databases
to limit the amount of connections. So if you
had six versions of the backend connecting to
the database, now that might be too much load
on the database, so that could cause problems.
And really, deployments are easily reverted. If
in the course of an upgrade, you notice
problems, it's usually easy to reverse
the rolling deployment by just going in the
opposite direction, removing a red adding a pink,
you can go in the opposite direction as
well to rollback which is an important
characteristic of deploying
because things always go wrong.
The downsides of rolling deployments are they
can be slow to run. So if you have 100 replicas,
and you're replacing one at a time, and it
takes 20 seconds, it would take 2000 seconds
to replace all of the versions, which
is quite a long time for deployment.
This can be mitigated by increasing the number of
services being turned on and shut off at a time,
which is sometimes called a burst
limit, or a rolling deployment size.
The other problem is API compatibility, which
is the biggest problem of rolling deployments.
So if you add a new version of an API endpoint to
your back end, and consume it in your front end,
then since you're not switching them both at
the same time, you might have version one of
your back end serving a request for version two of
your front end. And then that API wouldn't exist,
so there'd be errors visible to the user for
the duration of the deployment. This can be
mitigated with complicated routing techniques,
but it's generally better to make API is backwards
compatible. So make version two of the front end
be compatible with version one of the back end.
So rolling deployments are relatively simple
to understand and generally well supported.
If your users mind when there's
downtime, it's an excellent first step
to deploy using a rolling deployment strategy.
The key programming consideration is to ensure
that services can consume both the old version
and the new version of services API's. If this
contract was violated, users might see errors
for the duration of the deployments. Let's
talk more about deployment strategies.
And we'll go into bluegreen deployments.
Another deployment strategy people
often see are bluegreen deployments.
To set up a bluegreen. Deployment teams
need to disambiguate which services will be
consistently deployed, and which services will
be shared across versions of the application.
I'll explain a little bit more of what I mean by
that in the next section, a database server would
be a shared resource, multiple versions of the
app would connect to the server at the same time,
and a standard deployment would generally
not upgrade or modify the database.
In our mern example, all of the
other services or cluster resources,
new versions of them would be
deployed on every prod push.
So in a bluegreen deployment strategy, where
you're upgrading the JavaScript or the myrn app,
this is what that would look like. So there's
a blue version, and a green version of the
application where each is a fully standalone
stack. But we're each connects to a shared
database, and the database is not part of blue
or green. It's a shared resource used by both
bluegreen deployments are so called because they
maintain two separate clusters, one named blue and
one named green out of convention. If the current
version of the application is deployed to blue,
we deploy the new version to green
and use it as a staging environment
to ensure that the new version of the app
works correctly before setting users to it.
After we're confident that the new
version of the software works correctly,
we'd move over production load from blue to green,
and then repeat the cycle in
the opposite direction. So here
We started with the users being sent to blue,
which contains version one of the application. And
then we're investigating that version two works.
And after we're certain that version two works,
will route users to version two. And
then the version one is unused. And we
can shut it off and replace it with version three,
make sure it works, and then switch user traffic
over to it over and over again. On the benefits
side, bluegreen deployments are conceptually
very easy to understand. To set them up,
you just have to create two identical production
environments and send requests to either one or
the other, which is relatively simple with
services like Amazon elastic load balancing.
They're also quite powerful, longer running
tasks, like downloads can continue running
in the old version of the application after
traffic is switched over to the new version.
So if a user has an established
connection to green,
and you've switched everyone else over to blue,
that connection can continue finishing whatever
it was doing. So if you're watching video, and
you'd like to download it entirely to the user,
which might take minutes that can continue
going even during a prod push. Additionally,
bluegreen deployments can be extended to many
different workflows, which we'll discuss.
There's a few notable drawbacks to bluegreen
deployments, it's difficult to deploy a hotfix,
for example, to revert a change, because the
old cluster might be running longer running
tasks and unavailable to switch to. So if
you have version one of the application,
you switch over to version two, you realize
version two is having problems, you might want to
push version three very quickly, which addresses
those problems. But version one would be the
only place you could deploy version three. So you
wouldn't be able to do that. It's also finicky to
transfer load between the clusters, if resources
autoscale, which we'll talk about later on,
and load is transferred all at once the
new cluster might not have enough resources
allocated to serve the surge of requests, because
requests went all at once to peak production load.
And finally, if one cluster modifies the
shared service, like adding a column to a
table in the database, it may affect the other
cluster despite it not being the live one.
So here's some common extensions to
bluegreen deployments. As I mentioned,
they're very extensible. And many teams set up
advanced workflows around bluegreen deployments
to improve stability and deployment velocity. The
first idea is a natural extension of bluegreen
deployments, which I call rainbow deployments, but
I don't think there's a standard term for them.
Instead of only having two clusters, some
teams keep an arbitrary number of clusters,
so blue, green, red, yellow, so on. This is useful
when you're running very long running tasks.
If you're working on a distributed web scraper,
and you're scraping tasks take days, for example,
you might need your clusters to
last until the last job is finished,
to ensure things continue working as
expected. So with the rainbow deployments,
you'd keep all of the clusters that are
still processing tasks around or if you're
doing something like video encoding for long
videos, you don't want to shut off the cluster
that's in the middle of encoding a long video
because that work would have to be redone.
In a regular deployment of clusters
that only be shut off after all
of their long running jobs are done processing.
Some teams rely heavily on manual QA and
don't use continuous deployment. They're
often building desktop or mobile apps, which
needs to be published on longer release cycles.
So if example.com is being routed to the blue
cluster, it would be relatively simple to deploy
a new version of the application to the green
cluster endpoints new.example.com. to that. And
with this setup, the new version of the app could
be tested against the production database in the
very environment that will soon become production.
Such tests are often called acceptance tests,
because they're happening in production with
production data, with nothing like no privileged
access to the code base. So for a game, you might
have the new release available, or the API's for
the new release available and have your QA testers
test that. And after the QA testers give the Go
ahead, you can point the game client to the new
version, and then switch the labels of the to
another useful add on to bluegreen deployments.
And really deployments in general is called the
canary deployment. So if the new version of your
app contains subjective changes, such as editing
the UI, it might be ill advised to push them
to all users at once. Facebook has billions
of users. So if even 1% of their users complained
about a change, that would be overwhelming amounts
of feedback. The changes may break users workflows
and need to be modified or rolled back in response
to user feedback. So in the context of a bluegreen
deployments, a canary deployment would be to an
extension which routes maybe 5% of user traffic to
the new version of the application. And check that
those users don't have negative feedback before
switching the rest of the users over. So if blue
was version one green was version two, we'd have
95% going to version one. 5% going to version two
We'd wait to see if anyone on version two
complained. If not, then we'd route everyone
to version two. And we'd shut off version
one, and then put version three in that one.
So bluegreen deployments are powerful
and extensible deployment strategy
that works well with teams that
are deploying a few times per day.
With strategy only really starts being
problematic. It can use deployment scenarios,
where there's many services being
deployed many times per day.
Alright, let's keep talking about deployment.
And I'll see you in the next talk.
continuous deployment can sound daunting, but
it's not actually as difficult as it might seem,
in many cases. Let's take a look back at
our current example, and how it's deployed.
So, in our README, we've
helpfully added this little line, which is
how we're currently deploying to production.
If we look at our hosted version, slug, which is
hosted at this domain, we can see that the color
is still purple, despite having changed
the color to blue in the previous video.
The reason that it's still purple is
that we haven't production pushed,
we haven't pushed the new version of
the code, which contains the blue color.
And oftentimes, requiring human intervention
to deploy is simply unfeasible, especially as
product skill. So to deploy, let's run
the deployment process manually first,
and then let's talk about how to automate
it with a continuous deployment system.
So here, we'll use a terminal and simply
run the command directly from the read.
This developer computer comes with
the SSH key required to deploy
otherwise it would be difficult to
disseminate this SSH key to all developers,
which needed the ability to
deploy new versions of code.
Here we can see that it's
using Docker compose rebuilt,
we'll talk more about how to
set up a Docker file later on.
Now, if we refresh the page,
we can see that the deployment has
created a new version of the application,
which is blue, so it's picked up the color
change which was merged in the previous commit.
So continuous deployment, we'd like it to run on
merges to the main branch, we don't
want to deploy a feature branches
before they've been reviewed. For that,
we can set up a very simple configuration.
We could write this configuration
file in any directory,
but let's write it in the API directory for now.
So we'll create another layer file
will inherit from the testing layer file to
make sure that the deployment
runs after tests have passed.
And will only run the deployment
if the branch is the main branch.
However, if it is the main branch,
we'd like to set up a secret
and use that secret for our SSH key and
then use that SSH key to run the script.
Let's do that now.
And then hopefully gives us the
directives we need to expose the SSH key.
What's appose?
For now we're exposing the SSH key which is
used to authenticate with a production machine
within the CI process itself.
One other thing we need to do is change
the ownership to be more restrictive.
This is required for SSH, but it might not
be required for other deployment processes.
So now that we have our SSH key within the CI
server, and these steps are running after tests
are passed, all we have to do is copy our command
and run it as if it was part of a CI process.
All this configuration does is wait for tests to
pass, check that the branch is the main branch,
and then use the SSH key to deploy
a new version of the application.
Let's create a new pull request with
these changes and see how that looks.
We can see that as before the ephemeral
environment and ci services have being
built. But this API service is also being
built the API being the directory which
contains our continuous deployment process.
Let's take a look at what the pipeline
actually looks like Instructure.
so here we can see
that the application has been built successfully,
and is being started, just as in their
regular ci without CD process. So we're
running our continuous integration, but not our
continuous deployment step and this layer file.
And we can see the tests are running.
As usual, the test running process
requires starting a fake browser.
So this takes around 30 seconds.
And then after the tests pass, we'll see that the
deployment process runs. So the
tests lead to the second level.
graph, these are usually called
the build stages in a CI CD system.
So here, we can see
that the step was skipped because
the branch was not the main branch,
which is exactly what we wanted. However,
now if we merge this pull request,
we'll create a new merge branch on the main
branch. And we'll run the CI process once again.
Here.
And because this is the main branch,
the deployment process itself will be running.
So let's take a look at what that looks like.
We're simply loading the environment
to run the command and right now.
And here, we can see that the deployment
is running within ci itself. So instead of
needing to run it as an individual developer,
you can simply run this SSH command within ci.
And this idea of deploying automatically from
a CI process is called continuous deployment.
So let's work through that whole process
end to end once just to make sure that it's
clear on the deployment automation side of things.
So let's change the color, again, for the
main landing page, just to make sure that
it's visible if a change gets pushed correctly.
And again, we'll change the two colors.
And we'll create a new pull request.
And now our reviewer will have a lot of
information about whether this change is
good or not. So the reviewer will be
able to see both the files changed.
So they'll see all we've
done is change a few colors,
we'll be able to look at the CI process itself.
So they'll be able to see that tests are running.
So in particular, that the application
builds start successfully, tests run against,
they'll be able to look at
an ephemeral environment
within minutes of me creating this new change.
And if they approve the change, it'll be shown
to users in a short period of time, this whole
process will only take about a minute, with the
longest part being these automated browser tests.
One by one, these steps should become green.
Again, this is the base. This is the
ephemeral environment. This is the
continuous deployment process. And this is
the egg gets status. This is the one that
the administrators of GitHub might mark as
required. So that only if all of the checks pass,
can the commit be merged and shown to users. so
here we can see that everything has passed. Let's
take a look at the ephemeral environment just to
double check that the color is the one we want.
We can see that from the thermal
environment, we change the color to be this
rose ish red, perhaps this is the color
that was desired. So we'll say that this
is correct. And the test has passed and
successfully posted a message. So we know
that the functionality of the application
has continued to work after this change.
After we merge it
be the end to end test deploy
process for for this merge commit.
If we take a look at that,
we'll see that because we
merged to the main branch
the deployment is already running. in
production, we're creating a production build.
And in a short period of time, the production
server should have the latest version of
our application running on it. So here
it's restarting the production instance.
And the snapshot is being taken. So everything is
succeeded, we've successfully pushed if we go to
our website, it is now the shade of red that
we've changed. And that's what an end to end
ci CD, ephemeral environment pipeline
generally looks like at a very high level.
Alright, so let's talk more about
deployment automation in the next section,
talked about deployment strategies. But that's
not the only thing in deployments. Deployment
strategies help you reduce downtime and deploy
in a way that doesn't affect your users.
But another key consideration for deployment is
making sure that there's enough resources for
your containers or VMs. So that if there's a large
burst of users, your application doesn't go down.
So let's say you're building a CI system,
this hits close to home because I have
coursework at layer ci, a CI company,
your users would push code, you'd
have to spin up runners to run tests
against that code. And you'd see bursts of
traffic during the users business hours.
And you'd see significantly less
traffic outside of those business hours.
For a peak load of 10,000 concurrency runs,
you'd need at least 10,000 runners provisioned.
However, at night, outside of peak hours,
you wouldn't really need all 10,000
runners, most of them would sit idle.
So your usage might look like this, which
is also indicative of a lot of applications,
your lowest point is maybe 500. Runners required,
and your highest point is 10,000 runners required.
So you need 20 times more workers from the highest
points in the day to the lowest points in the day.
In an ideal world, you'd be able to create or
destroy these runners as necessary. during peak
hours, you'd be able to create new ones, and then
off peak hours, you'd be able to destroy them.
That's the idea for auto scaling.
It's only possible to create and destroy
workers because of cloud providers.
At their enormous scale, it's possible
to offer servers for cheap on small one
hour leases. The most popular technology
at the time of this post or this video,
is AWS easy to spot instances, which act exactly
like cloud hosted VMs with large discounts if
you provision them for short periods of time.
Another popular technology for auto scaling
is Kubernetes horizontal pod auto scaling, which
sounds daunting. But since many providers provide
Kubernetes out of the box, you can just assume
that if you're using Kubernetes, and containers,
you'll get auto scaling if you configure
it correctly. Just to illustrate,
if you're using Microsoft's as your as your cloud
provider, there's resources for auto scaling
VMs. And for containers. If you're using AWS,
there's again, resources for VMs and containers.
And if you're using Google Cloud, there's
resources for VMs and containers. auto
scaling is usually discussed on the timeline
of one hour chunks of work. If you took the
concept of auto scaling and took it to its limit,
you'd get serverless defined resources that are
quickly started and use them on the timeline
of milliseconds. So one to 100 milliseconds.
For example, a web server might not need to
exist at all until a visitor requests the page.
Instead, it could be spun up specifically for that
request, serve the page and then shut back down.
That's exactly the idea for serverless.
It's almost like taking auto scaling, so
provisioning resources as the required and doing
it very quickly on very small time intervals.
serverless is primarily used for services
that are somewhat fast to start in stateless,
you wouldn't run something like a CI job
or a CI run within a serverless framework.
But you might run something like a
web server or notification service.
auto scaling is primarily used for services
that are slower to start or require state, you'd
likely run a CI job within an auto scaled VM or
container, and not within a serverless container.
As a 2021, the distinction between the models is
becoming quite blurred. serverless containers are
becoming popular. And they often run for upwards
of an hour. serverless containers act exactly like
containers, but they're created and turned off in
a serverless manner. So in response to a trigger.
Within a few years, it's likely
that serverless and auto scaling
will converge into a single unified interface.
So I'm excited about that. That's that's
going to be the future of deployment.
And that ends our discussion of auto scaling
and serverless. I'll see you in the next talk.
Another key concept in deployment
automation is service discovery.
A database might be at one IP address, so 10 dot
1.1 dot 1.6 by four three chosen arbitrarily,
while the web server would be at
another IP address 10.1 dot 1.2 8080.
And they'd have to discover each other, because
the web server needs to talk to the database,
and the database might have
calls to the web server,
those get even more complicated as you add more
copies of your web server, or add entirely new
services. Again, let's consider the myrn app
from elsewhere in the academy DevOps series.
So you have a web browser, the user themselves is
visiting your website. They're connecting to your
front end, and they're connecting
to your backend making API calls.
And your back end is connecting to a database.
Here, there's three services that need to be
discovered. The browser needs to learn that
example.com corresponds to the front end,
an example.com slash API corresponds to the
back end. And the back end needs to land on the
database is that 10.111 dot 1.3, for example.
So the backend needs to know the IP address and
port of the database. And the browser needs to
know the IP address and port of the backend and
the front end. In the very simplest configuration,
everything is manually configured the back end
and front end or add static IPS. And given host
names within DNS Domain Name System, it's the
mapping of example.com to an IP address on the
internet. And the back end is configured
to connect to MongoDB at a specific port.
So your DNS configuration, this is the CloudFlare
configuration page, which has a DNS provider
would look like this. So if the user visits
example.com, send them to this IP address.
And if they visit api.example.com,
send them to that IP address.
So this is all manually configured. And we've
just manually put the IP addresses in this.
And then within the backend, we'd
read an environment variable,
which is a dictionary of key value pairs that
are easily set when you're deploying things. So
you'd say connect to the environment
variable, specifying the MongoDB port,
and then connect to Port 27017,
which is the default MongoDB port.
And then when you're starting the backend,
you just have to specify the IP
address that MongoDB is running in.
This configuration is completely fine. For
simple products, it's difficult to mess up.
It's relatively secure, and it doesn't over
complicate things, you can go pretty far with a
simple configuration. Most products could launch
an MVP without any service discovery at all.
But you'll know that you need to start caring
about complicating your service discovery when
you see one of the following. So you need zero
downtime deployments. You can't hard code things
like this if you want to do rolling deployments.
Because you can't easily automate where the
arrows point to, you can't automatically change
the IP address. If you're doing such a simple
deployment strategy. For example, if you have
more than a couple microservices, it's gonna
get hard to remember where they all are. And if
you're deploying to several environments, like
if you have a developer environment, a staging
environment, and ephemeral environments, and
production environments that all have different
IP addresses, it's gonna get pretty unwieldy to
set the IP addresses all over the place. So let's
focus on zero downtime deployments because they're
illustrative of the broader problem. Before
that, though, let's talk about reverse proxies,
which are another crucial system design and
DevOps concept. The idea for a zero downtime
deployment is simple. As we've seen, you start
a new version of the back end and front end, you
wait till they're up, and then you shut off the
old version of the backend and front end. So this
happens in both rolling and bluegreen deployments.
However, it's difficult to update the IP addresses
in DNS itself. If our rolling deployments
required changing these values directly in DNS,
that wouldn't work very well, for various
reasons. And particular, DNS can take a long
time to propagate users in other countries than
the United States, for example, might take days
to see the new IP address, and they'd still
be trying to connect to the old version.
The solution is to add a web server that acts
as the gateway to the front end and back end,
we'd be able to change where it points to
without changing the DNS configuration itself.
So web servers like these are called
reverse proxies. And they're really
crucial for setting up zero downtime
deployments, and for service discovery itself.
So taking our myrn app and adding this level
of complexity, the user's web browser would
instead connect to the reverse proxy. So the user
would ask the DNS system where is example.com
The DNS system would respond with, oh, it's here,
the IP address of the reverse proxy. And then
the reverse proxy would take the user's request
and send it to the appropriate, they view
on that front end or back end, depending
on what the user asked to connect to. And then
from there, everything else would be the same.
So if you're running a deployments,
like a rolling deployments,
the proxy could choose which of v1 or v2
of the front end or back end to send the
users request to, and that would just
be by changing a configuration file.
And then after your deployment is done, you
could turn off version one, and the reverse
proxy could route traffic entirely diversion
to a straightforward approach is to store the
service IPS in a hash table. So implicitly,
in the process of running at the moment,
we assumed that our reverse proxy would be able
to know the IPS of the new versions of our apps,
which is exactly the statements of service
discovery. And so that needing to manually
tell our reverse proxy where the front
end and back end live. So where is the
IP address of version two of our back end, it
would be convenient if we could automate it.
When the new versions come online,
they can update the value for the key back end and
front end with their own IPS in this hash table.
And then the reverse proxy could watch for changes
to the table and use that for routing decisions.
For a very concrete example, which is about
as close as we're going to get to code in this
set of videos, let's look
at this nginx configuration.
nginx is a very popular reverse proxy. And it's
very commonly used in large tech companies.
And it lets you define where various host names
go, if you pointed example.com, to the nginx,
reverse proxy, again, in the picture, this
would be nginx, the user thinks they're
connecting to your website, but they'd
be sending the request to nginx. Asking,
for example, COMM And nginx would take their
example and forward it to your actual front end.
So nginx just has to learn where
the IP for your front end is.
And that's what this configuration would
do. So we're telling nginx directly,
take this key from this file,
and then use conf D, which reads from a hash
table and updates the configuration file,
and then send the user there. So
all you need is a key value store, which has a
key fob where the front end IP is the current
front end version. And then to run your rolling
deployments, you'd start a new front end version,
check that it was alive, and then you just change
the key in the hash table to point to the new one.
And then constantly would pick up that
change, replace this value with the new IP
of version two of the front
end, and then reload nginx,
which would change the arrow to the
new version of the front end like this.
That was a lot to deal with. So
let's back up a bit, all you'd need
to do is update your front end,
to set the key in the hash table for
IPS front end to be the front ends IP,
and then make your back end do the
same for the back end location.
And that way, when the new version of the
application starts, it would update the key
in the table. And then nginx would start routing
users to the new version of the application.
This is what proxy passing means and nginx. So
you see this proxy pass directive.
But this is all very complicated.
It's just an illustrative point of if you were
to implement this yourself, how would you do it?
The most common thing used in industry
is service discovery by using DNS itself.
So DNS, we thought of before as the
slow protocol that might take days
to propagate changes across the
network. But you can run DNS locally.
And that's the industry standard.
So let's talk about DNS a little bit.
The idea for DNS is just to map host names to
IPS. When you visit layer ci.com. For example,
the global DNS system will first map
the name latest.com, to the addresses
at the time of this video 104 dot 217 9.86 and
172 dot six 7.16 9.106, which are just arbitrary
computers connected to the internet. And you
can use the Digg command on a website to see
where those addresses are. So this is saying for
the key layer ci.com the values are these two.
And usually when people mentioned
DNS, they mean the global service.
So visiting websites on the internet. However, as
I mentioned, it's possible to run DNS internally.
It would be ideal if in our nginx configuration,
we could specify HTTP full colon slash slash front
end and then have front end resolve
to the IP of our front end service.
That way we wouldn't have to change
anything except for the DNS configuration.
That's exactly how DNS based
service discovery works.
you configure your services to query a server
you control for DNS queries and then this
So instead of saying MongoDB, full colon
slash slash, process and MongoDB, you just say
MongoDB full colon slash slash
Mongo, where Mongo is a key
in the key value pairs in
the DNS that you control.
Of course, it's not trivial to deploy
your own DNS server. In practice,
though there are popular options like core DNS,
the most likely thing you do is use a cloud
provider or Kubernetes internal solutions.
So the end result you'd
get is something like this,
the user's web browser would connect to nginx.
Thinking it was the website nginx would ask
the DNS provider, where is the API right
now, the cloud provider would respond with
this is the IP address, given the deployments,
so blue, green, or rolling deployments,
this is what we currently want users to visit
when they want to visit the API. And then
this would correspond to version
one or version two of the backend.
And then the proxy would
forward the request there,
the request to be fulfilled, and then we go
back to the proxy, and then back to the user.
So the conclusion of all of this is that service
discovery is tricky, but vitally important as a
foundational building block for these deployment
strategies. And for deployment automation in
general, if you configure service discovery
in an appropriate manner for your deployments,
so DNS based in a Kubernetes cluster, for example,
it makes significantly easier for developers to
have microservices that talk to each other,
instead of having a developer have to write
connect a MongoDB app, and then deal with where
MongoDB actually is. They can simply say connect
to MongoDB at MongoDB colon slash slash Mongo.
And then you as the DevOps platform engineer can
configure where that Mongo always points to the
right place the right IP address. By decoupling
the application logic from the deployment
logic, you'll help the developers on your
team build faster, and you'll be able to deploy
it more easily. So that's it for deployments.
Let's go on to the next and final pillar,
which is application performance management.
There aren't that many general topics
in application performance management,
so this section will be a little bit shorter.
We'll go into more detail in future sections
in the DevOps Academy. But just
for this introductory video series,
let's talk about two core concepts.
The first of which is log aggregation.
And it's a way of collecting and tagging
application logs from many different services
into a single dashboard that can easily be
searched. One of the first systems that have to be
built out in an application performance management
system is log aggregation. Just as a reminder,
application performance management is the part
of the DevOps lifecycle where things have been
built and deployed. And you need to make
sure that they're continuously working
so they have enough resources allocated to
them. And errors aren't being shown to users.
In most production deployments, there are many
related events that emit logs across services. At
Google, a single search might hit five different
services before being returned to the user. If you
got unexpected search results, that might mean
a logic problem in any of the five services.
And log aggregation helps companies like
Google diagnose problems in production,
they built a single dashboard where they can
map every request unique ID. So if you search
something, your search will get a unique ID
and then every time that search is passing
through a different service, that service will
connect that ID to what they're currently doing.
This is the essence of a good
log aggregation platform,
efficiently collect logs from everywhere that
emits them and make them easily searchable.
In the case of a fault. Again, this is our
main app, the users web browser connects to
a back end and the front end, and the
back end then connects to a database.
If the user told us, the page turned
all white and printed an error message,
we would be hard pressed to diagnose
the problem with our current stack,
the user would need to manually send us the
error and we'd need to match it with relevant
logs in the other three services. Let's
take a look at Elk, a popular open source
log aggregation stack named after its three
components, Elasticsearch, LogStash and cabana.
If we installed it in our burn app, we'd get three
new services. So the users web browser, again
would connect to our front end and back end. The
back end would connect to Mongo, and all of these
services, the browser, the front end, the back
end and Mongo would all send logs to LogStash.
And then the way that these three components work,
the components of ALK Elasticsearch Log
Stash and cabana is that all of the others
Services send logs to LogStash. LogStash
takes these logs, which are text emitted by
the application. For example, the web browser.
When you visit a web page, the web page might
log this visitor access this page at this
time. And that's an example of a log message.
Those logs would be sent to LogStash, which would
extract things from them. So for that log message,
user did thing a time, it would extract the time
and extract the message and extract the user and
include those all as tags. So the message
would be an object of tags and message so
that you could search them easily. You could say,
find all of the requests made by a specific user.
But LogStash doesn't store things itself.
It stores things in Elasticsearch,
which is efficient database for querying text.
And Elastic Search exposes the results as Kibana
and cabana is a web server that connects
to Elasticsearch and allows administrators
as the DevOps person or other people
on your team, the on call engineer to
view the logs in production
whenever there's a major fault.
So you as the administrator would connect to
cabana cabana would query Elastic Search for
logs matching whatever you wanted. You could say,
hey, cabana, in the search bar, I want to find
errors. And cabana would say Elastic Search
finds the messages which contain the string
error. And then Elasticsearch would return
results that had been populated by LogStash
and LogStash would have been samples
results from all of the other services.
If you visited a web page, this might
be the sort of log that is emitted.
And it might be processed into an object like
this. So it has a format, a date, and a simple
time format. That's the same for all messages
emitted by all different services, you'd have a
service which service submitted the log, and you'd
have the message, the actual content of the log.
And the processor, LogStash itself would often
be connected to the internet so that JavaScript
in the browser can catch errors and send them to
LogStash. Although there are additional services
like century that might be better suited
for that. How would we use elk to diagnose
a production problem? Well, let's say a user says
I saw error code 1234567. When I tried to do this,
with elk setup, we'd have to go to cabana, enter
1234567 in the search bar, press Enter. And then
that would show us the logs that corresponded
to that. And one of the logs might say, internal
server error returning 1234567. And we'd see that
the service that emitted that log was back end,
and we'd see what time that blog was
emitted at. So we could go to the
time in that log. And we could look
at the messages above and below it
in the backend. And then we could see a better
picture of what happened for the user's request.
And we'd be able to repeat this process
going to other services until we found
what actually caused the problem for the user.
The final piece of the puzzle is ensuring
that logs are only visible to administrators.
As logs can contain sensitive information like
tokens, it's important that only authenticated
users can access them. You wouldn't want to
expose Kibana to the internet without some
way of authenticating. My favorite way of doing
this is to add a reverse proxy like nginx. Again,
our friend nginx and then have the auth request
mechanism check that the user is logged in.
So in our back end, we could
add something like this,
which simply returns a successful status. If
the user visits example.com slash auth request
and there an admin, it would return a successful
status. And if they're not admin, it would return
an unauthorized status. And then we could
configure nginx. Again, as mentioned in previous
videos, to have these location blocks, the slash
private location would connect to slash off.
And then we could make sure that if this was slash
logs, for example, that the user was logged in,
because with this auth request directive, if
the user visits slash logs, and they're not an
administrator, they wouldn't be able to access
them. Alternatively, Elasticsearch itself is run
by a company called elastic and they have a paid
version, which contains something called x pack,
which facilitates this as well. So you can go for
either a reverse proxy which authenticates users,
or the paid version of the application.
As an aside, you can use log
aggregation as an extra test.
So in your ci pipelines, where you
want to tell if code is good or not,
you can repurpose your log aggregation stack
to ensure that no warnings or errors occur
while the tests run. If your end to end test
looks like this. So you're starting your stack,
you're starting your logging stack. You're
running your tests with NPM run test. You could
add an extra step which queries Elastic Search for
logs matching error, and you could make sure that
There are no logs, that printed error.
And then even if all of your tests pass,
if there's an error going on, that error might
be important despite all the tests passing.
So this adds a free extra check to your ci stack.
And there's a few examples of log aggregation
platforms. There's Elasticsearch, LogStash,
Kibana, which we talked about, there's fluent D
is another popular open source choice. There's
data dog, which is very commonly used at larger
enterprises. It's a hosted offering. And there's
log DNA, which is another hosted offering.
And those cloud providers also provide logging
facilities like AWS, cloudwatch logs. So log
aggregation is a key tool for diagnosing problems
in production. It's relatively simple to install
a turnkey solution like elk or cloud watch,
and it makes diagnosing and triage problems
and production significantly easier.
That's it for log aggregation.
I'll see you in the next talk.
Plus topic we're going to talk
about is metric aggregation.
metrics are simply data points that tell
you how healthy production is. So as you
can see on the screen, things like CPU usage,
memory usage, disk IO, file, system fullness,
are all important production metrics that you
might care about. If log aggregation is the
first tool to set up for production monitoring,
metrics, monitoring would be the second. They're
both indispensable for finding production faults,
and debugging performance and stability problems.
Log aggregation primarily deals with text,
logs or textual Of course. In contrast,
metric aggregation deals with numbers. How
long did something take his memory being used?
It's frighteningly difficult to understand
what's going on in a production system.
Netflix, for example, measures
2.5 billion different time series
to monitor the health of their production
deployments. Successful metric monitoring is
being able to automatically notify the necessary
teams when something goes wrong in production.
Let's keep looking at open source implementations
of DevOps tools to keep things general.
Prometheus is a tool originally deployed at
SoundCloud is one of the most popular metrics
servers. And this is what it looks like. Similarly
structured, the inputs are sent to the retrieval,
things like nodes would send how much disk usage
they have to the media server, but also how
long services are taking ALC itself would parse
numbers out of logs and send them to permit this.
And then promethease figures out what get services
from using service discovery from the previous
video. And then it takes those and it stores it
in a time series database equivalent for numbers,
what Elasticsearch is for text, and then that
stored on the Prometheus server node itself.
And then finally, there's a front end. So other
services can query promethease. To do things, one
thing you might want to do is if there's something
terribly wrong, like your website is down,
you might want to connect a pager duty
or email someone or send someone a text
message with Twilio, beyond call engineer
and tell them that something is wrong.
But you might also want to query
metrics to get a view like this one.
And that's what prom qL is used for. So grafana
is the view that dark view with the graphs.
And it's common way of viewing these
time series. But you can make your own
and you can make API's. And there's many
other front ends that connected previous.
The diagram above is daunting, but it's quite
similar to the architecture that we discussed
for log aggregation frameworks. There's four key
components. Like I mentioned, the time series
database actually stores the measurements,
retrieval, the alert manager and the web UI.
So the sorts of metrics we collect. Well,
there's a lot of subjectivity about which
metrics are important based on what your
product does and what your users are.
But here's a few ideas for what you
store in something like promethease.
So request fulfillment times, these are very
useful for understanding when systems are
getting overloaded, or if a newly pushed
change has negatively impact performance.
The format times are often parsed out of
logs using a regular expression, for example,
or taken out of a field in a database.
For a website or REST API, a common request
fulfillment time would be time to response
for web sites and rest API's. A common request
fulfillment time would be time to response.
That way slow web pages could be
discovered and identified in production.
A related metric that is very indicative of
problems his request counts, and if there's
a huge spike in requests per second, it's
very likely that at least a few production
systems will have trouble scaling. Watching
request counts can also be used to detect and
mitigate attacks like denial of service attacks,
which are when attackers sent many malicious
requests to services in production.
The last common metric across many
types of companies is server resources.
Here's a few examples. So the database size
and maximum database size. If you have two
terabytes of disk for your database and your 1.5
terabytes in, you might want to alert someone to
increase the amount of disk available for the
database or delete things that are being unused
web server memory. So if your web server
is taking a lot of requests per second and
doing a lot of processing, it might require
more memory. So if it runs out of memory,
it would crash and your users wouldn't
be able to access your website anymore.
Network throughput. So if you're downloading
many things, or uploading many things,
you can saturate your network. And that
would also cause degraded performance.
And a final one is TLS certificate expiry
time. So this lock in the browser that uses
TLS certificates to see whether the browser
is secure or not, are used all over the place
internally. And these cause problems if they're
not measured, and they're not alerted for.
So for example, Google Voice had an outage in
2021, Google of all companies wasn't measuring
when their TLS certificates would expire.
And that caused an outage a few months ago.
So production faults very rarely look
like no users can access anything.
There are often a gradual ramp,
certain API's taking longer and longer,
and then eventually everything breaks. portal
analysis is an easy way to pare down production
statistics into something actionable. A website
might measure how long it takes for websites to
fully load their landing page to notice
when there's a very obvious production
issue. So with cuartel analysis, you'd split
request times and many different buckets.
How long did the slowest 1% of users take?
How long did the slowest 5% of users take?
How long did the slowest 25% of users take.
So if your landing page is slower when users
are logged in and logged out, just by visiting
without a logged in user, you might not notice
that the web page is very slow. But users
that are logged in, would show up in the 1%
of requests bucket, and you'd see that those
users are having a bad degraded experience.
Or when example stackoverflow.com itself was
notified of an outage because their landing
page was taking a long time to respond
to requests due to a specific post that
was published to stack overflow. For metrics
analysis, there's many common production tools.
There's Prometheus and grafana. As we
mentioned, there's data dog, again,
not only log aggregation, but metrics aggregation
as well. There's New Relic, which is I would say
maybe the old reliable option. And there's
again, cloud providers by their own versions
of this. There's AWS cloudwatch metrics, Google
Cloud monitoring, and as your monitor metrics.
That's it for application performance
management. Thanks for watching.